Opposers,
I love America.
It's been perfect
ever since day one,
when the Pilgrims landed
at Plymouth Rock
and immediately refused to bake
a cake for some gay Indians.
(laughter)
On religious grounds.
I love it here in America,
but I've got to be honest.
Sometimes, when I look around,
I don't recognize
my country anymore.
♪ ♪
(cheers and applause)
First up-- female cocks,
or as they call them "chickens."
(laughter)
There's nothing more American
than KFC.
You got "Kentucky ,"
you got "Fried,"
and you got a weaker creature's
blood on your hands.
(laughter)
America.
Well, not anymore.
KFC is developing
a vegetarian fried chicken.
A spokesperson says the offering
is aimed at healthy eaters.
Vegetarian fried chicken?!
That's an oxymoron!
Like government efficiency,
or unflattering picture
of Eric Trump.
(laughter)
Leave your recipe alone, KFC.
It's our president's
favorite thing to eat
after cheeseburgers
and Paul Ryan's integrity.
(laughter)
I mean, meatless chicken?
Come on!
That's not the America I know.
Am I even in America anymore?
It sure doesn't feel like it.
You know what? Maybe I'm not.
Maybe I'm in some other country,
like-- I don't know--
-Finland!
-♪ ♪
And I'm polishing
Olympic hockey medals
with my friends Lena
and Alexander,
and going
to the public library--
because this country has
the highest rate
of book borrowing per capita--
before an afternoon of hiking
through the 78% of the country
that's covered in forests while
the rest is (bleep) fjords!
Ugh!
Next up-- man's best friend.
Statues.
I love statues.
They're a great way
to commemorate American heroes
who loved this country so much,
they waged war against it.
(laughter)
But now, some new statues
are coming to town.
WOMAN: New York City is now
launching the
She Built NYC Campaign.
First Lady Chirlane McCray says
finding a memorial or statue
to instrumental women
in New York City is like going
on a "scavenger hunt."
When there are no
representations of the women
who built this city,
women of all ethnicities,
the message is
that women's contributions
are worth less than men's.
Hey, lady, what do you mean
you need more statues of women?
You already have
the tallest one.
(laughter)
And she's great!
She's holding a book.
She's supposed to welcome
everyone to the country.
If you think about it,
the Statue of Liberty is
America's bitchy hostess.
(laughter)
"I'm sorry, but our poor, tired,
huddled masses section is,
"like, so full.
You can go wait at the bar.
It's a detention center."
(laughter, groaning)
(whispering):
It's a cage.
(laughter)
So I guess this organization
is mad that there are nearly
150 historical male statues
in New York,
and only five female statues,
but that can't be true.
There are so many statues
of women. I see 'em everywhere.
Always staring out of windows
at me,
judging my cargo shorts,
wearing lingerie in public.
Some of them
don't even have heads!
And none of them are my mom!
I never said they were.
I mean, come on.
More statues of women?!
What is this?
This isn't my country.
What happened to the America
I know and love?
Maybe I'm not there anymore.
Maybe I'm in (bleep) Barbados.
-(laughter)
-♪ ♪
And I'm dancing
at the Crop Over Festival
with a nearly naked
and bedazzled Rihanna.
And we're giggling
about the country's
near 100% literacy rate
before we drunkenly sashay down
to one of the many beaches
for a meal of Cou Cou.
And if I choke on flying fish,
it's okay,
because we have
nationalized health care! Ugh.
Next up...
The Incredibles 2
came out last week,
and hot on its heels,
the PC police
at the New York Post published
an article called:
"Hey Perverts, Stop Staring
at Elastigirl's Butt."
Now, Elastigirl is the mom,
and, personally,
I barely noticed her.
I was too busy admiring
what I would look like
with bleached hair.
(laughter)
But apparently, a lot of people
noticed that Elastigirl is a...
"Thicc Superhero Queen."
(laughter)
So what?
Are we not allowed to sexualize
cartoon characters anymore?
That's a proud
American tradition.
From Betty Boop to Daphne
to Rosie the Robot maid.
(laughter)
Sweet, sweet Rosie.
Perhaps the thiccest
of them all.
(laughter)
Just look at that
sexy maid outfit.
Those angry red eyes.
-Those sensual claw hands.
-(laughter)
That double-guillotine mouth.
Oh! And listen to her.
I could help you, Miss Judy.
I'm wired to tape analysis.
-Ooh, she's nasty.
-(laughter)
Look, if we can't sexualize
cartoon characters,
what the (bleep)
are we even doing?
Honestly. I don't feel
like I'm in America.
I feel like I'm in...
-Hell...
-(flames crackling)
floating down the River Styx
with some loser boat demon
insists that I pay him a fare.
No way, dude.
This is a damn rowboat.
And I didn't even choose
to come aboard.
I'm keeping my 50 cents.
And now I have to make
small talk with Stalin
and that gorilla
that stole sign language?
-No way.
-(laughter)
This place sucks.
You know, I can't stand it
anymore. This is too much.
Chuck. Chuck.
Bring me back, man.
Tell me this isn't Hell and that
I'm still in the country I love.
Is U.S. politics
still dominated by men?
CHUCK: Yes. But a
record-breaking number of women
are running for office
this year.
What? Chuck...
normally,
at the end of this segment,
you give me some reassurance
that America is not changing.
CHUCK: To be honest,
the country is changing.
There's growing diversity--
movements like #MeToo.
I had a veggie burger for lunch,
and it was okay.
-Okay.
-(laughter)
You're saying that
not all change is bad?
Maybe I should try it.
-Chuck, you're fired.
-Wait, what?
The fight continues.